The X Files have been terminated Mulder
we have been reassigned it's over and
done reassignment on The X Files and
denied trust no one was domanda
greetings I'm Gabe po rudder and for
those of you who are too young to have
watched the x-files but still kind of
pretend to get the references I'm here
to catch you up on why this show coming
back is the coolest thing since the
government found him in my backyard it's
true this is hashtag news fox announced
that the x-files will return for six
episodes with original stars David
Duchovny and Gillian Anderson yes and
production set begin this summer the
x-files ran for nine seasons from 1993
to 2002 spawned two movies and it was
one of the all-time best TV shows about
the supernatural what about that show
supernatural yeah don't talk to me okay
you have a garbage brain I can't help
you what was the x-files about it's
centered around two FBI agents believer
Fox Mulder and skeptic Dana Scully is
they investigated strange cases while
gradually unraveling a massive
government cover-up spoiler it's aliens
what else would the government need to
hide drone strikes corruption no no just
aliens so why is the x-files so awesome
you know those crazy conspiracy theories
that stoner you went to high school with
always posts on Facebook the show is
basically written by him that is if you
went to high school with the series
writer Vince Gilligan who went on to
create Breaking Bad well maybe you went
to high school with writer Michelle
Maclaren who's worked on Game of Thrones
and the walking dead or maybe writer
howard gordon who wrote 24 in homeland
oh look at you i schooled the stars even
Walter White appeared in an episode is a
guy with a bomb implanted in his head I
didn't even realize it was Walter White
until recently I wasn't like him in that
episode basically the x-files are the
cool parents of all the shows that you
know and love today not only did it help
put Fox on the map in the 90s it proved
high-concept serialized television could
be popular which helped pave the way for
tons of the shows that we love now think
of the x-files like a cool vintage
version of lost except instead of the
Dharma Initiative and the smoke monster
there's the US government in the smoking
man or think of it like the walking dead
except instead of the world infested
with zombies the world is infested with
super intelligent aliens disguised as
humans or think of it like fringe except
it's exactly like fringe so where will
this new 6 episode season pick up we'll
Mulder and Scully still be on the run
from the
well the mysterious smoking man come
back pull my mom ever return my phone
calls we'll have to wait and see and
most importantly if and when a character
does get abducted by aliens lippi for
creative reasons or because the actor
was a pain in the ass to work with well
I guess my level oh alright yeah very
funny guys okay fine but no but stuff if
you enjoyed this video please like it
below and comment with your thoughts and
predictions for the new season of The X
Files subscribe by hitting the button
below that says subscribe part of the
fun guys for community you like each
other it subscribe alright I'm gay bro
writer and 17 days ago my yogurt
banished from the break room fridge my
life is defined by the search for the
truth oh there it is yeah left out to
left out mr. salt
and